merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame marianne dubois merci monsieur
le président monsieur premier ministre
alors que nous nous apprêtons à
commémorer la fin des combats de la
première guerre mondiale
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
les difficultés financières que
rencontre aujourd'hui nos associations
d'anciens combattants en supprimant la
clause de compétence générale la loi
nôtre est venue limiter le financement
de ces associations par les départements
ce qui compromet sensiblement leur
équilibre
l'article 104 de la loi énumère par
ailleurs les compétences partagées
possible dans un certain nombre de
domaines au rang desquels ne figure pas
le soutien aux associations d'anciens
combattants perpétuer une aile une aide
annuelle en fonctionnement purement
administratif aux associations d'anciens
combattants ne paraît donc plus
légalement possible
ici nous avons affaire à un antagonisme
entre le légal et légitime
d'un côté une loi qui interdit une
subvention annuelle de fonctionnement au
profit d'associations d'anciens
combattants à qui nous devons notre
liberté de l'autre la légitimité d'une
reconnaissance éternelle à nos soldats
morts pour la france
d'un côté le risque d' attribué de
manière hétérogène une aide illégale
de l'autre le devoir de mémoire au
moment où même nous commémorons le
centenaire de la guerre 14 18
il est inconcevable que les départements
soient contraints à de réels contorsions
avec le droit pour financer leurs
associations d'anciens combattants comme
leur attachement au titre de l'éducation
populaire ou à mettre en avant des
arguties juridiques pour leur expliquer
que la loi nôtre est malheureusement
responsables de leur extinction
ainsi monsieur le premier ministre
confirmez vous votre volonté à travers
la loi notre d'interdire aux
départements d'entretenir le devoir de
mémoire par leur soutien aux
associations d'anciens combattants
je vous remercie merci madame la parole
et par monsieur jean marc todeschini
secrétaire d'état chargé des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire
oui monsieur le président madame la
députée du bois vous m'interrogez sur le
financement des associations d'anciens
combattants
suite à l'entrée en à l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi d'autres qui supprime
la clause de compétence générale des
régions et des départements et il
concernera désormais que les communes
je connais d'inquiétude qui pourrait
naître dans le monde associatif
combattants néanmoins faut-il polémiquer
sur un sujet comme celui là
à ce jour le ministère en ministère n'a
pas été sollicité directement sur ce
sujet en ce qui concerne l'action que je
mène au sein de ce ministère
je souhaite vous rassurer et rassurer
l'ensemble du monde combattant qui eux
ne sont pas pour le moment
affolée nous continuerons à en financer
des associations dans les mêmes termes
que juste alors l'ensemble des
opérateurs et les services de l'état
sont mobilisés à travers la direction de
la mémoire du patrimoine et des archives
du ministère de la défense
l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre et
l'addition du centenaire au plus près
des territoires nous siano soutiendront
comme nous l'avons toujours fait les
projets associatifs qui concerne des
actions mémorielle où l'action sociale
envers les anciens combattants et
notamment les jeunes écoutent l'arrêt
savez combien les valeurs la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
et de toutes les mémoires vers les plus
jeunes citoyennes demain sont
importantes
nous avons fait de cet enjeu de
transmission un enjeu notre de notre
action je voulais vous signaler tout
simplement que le ministère de la
défense finance tous les projets
pédagogiques qui lui sont soumis et à
titre d'exemple en 2015 je vous dirai
tout simplement que le ministère la
défense a versé peu plus près de 4
millions d'euros de fonctionnement aux
associations en tout cas le gouvernement
est attentif des quotas aux actions du
monde combattant à ce et vous l'avez dit
à juste titre at il ou devant nos
libertés et je suis sûr que les
associations d'anciens combattants
continueront à jouer leur rôle
malgré le changement du mode de
financement je remercie